this episode is made possible by
curiositystream
get free access to nebula the streaming
platform built by all your favorite
youtubers when you sign up for
curiositystream at the link below
[Music]
if you live in what's commonly called
the western world especially in the
united states
you've no doubt heard the claim that
capitalism is the most efficient system
for the distribution of products
and that this is thanks to the miracle
of the free market a completely organic
system by which the true value
of goods and services are determined as
i've mentioned in recent videos
american faith in the economic structure
of capitalism is on the decline
but arguments for the effectiveness of
the system are still very common
in this episode we're going to take a
look at one of the more common ones
the assertion that capitalism is
efficient let's start with that word
efficient what is efficiency the
dictionary definition is
effective operation as measured by a
comparison of production with
cost as in energy time and money the
capitalist understanding of that
definition is where we get into trouble
capitalism is driven by the profit
motive the pursuit of ever greater
financial gain regardless of actual
economic performance with that vision in
mind
efficiency can be defined as making the
smallest possible investment
or expending the least amount of energy
or resources to ensure
increasing profits and minimum
acceptable function or quality
this capitalist translation of
efficiency causes some serious problems
which we'll explore later but first we
need to address some misconceptions
espoused by the type of person who tends
to claim capitalism is efficient
first and foremost there is a common
misconception that capitalism is defined
by markets
that if a system has markets it's
capitalism that is not the case
take feudalism for example as a system
that existed well before the birth of
capitalism
it cannot be claimed that feudalism was
capitalist and yet feudalism had markets
serfs produced goods which they handed
over to their lords
and which those lords then sold in
markets sometimes even the serfs had
access to markets
okay but if capitalism isn't defined by
markets
if markets existed long before
capitalism what does define it
opinions can vary but if you ask me i
would say capitalism is defined by three
core philosophies
first the drive for short-term profits
over long-term stability
second the rigid stratification of the
owner class and the working class
and third a devotion to imperialist
expansion and infinite growth
as socialists have correctly pointed out
for well over a century
the tendencies of capitalism do not lend
themselves to market efficiency
but rather towards military oppression
of foreign populations
over-exploitation of workers and natural
resources
and increasingly frequent economic
crises all of these observations have
proven their accuracy many times over
capitalism relies on the exploitation of
workers at home
and abroad and this working class is
entirely at the mercy of those who own
the companies which put them to work
in reality these workers are often more
excluded from capitalist markets than
even feudal surfs
because the modern worker does not own
any of the goods or services they
produce
okay why does that matter it matters
because if the workers are excluded from
the market system
that means only a tiny minority of
wealthy and powerful people
the owner class has access to the
so-called free market
but the selling of products on the
market is only half the equation
the other half is production similar to
the sale of products by the owner class
the production of those products is also
controlled by the wealthy and powerful
those who own the means of production a
factory a pharmaceutical lab a
supermarket chain
decide what is produced how it is
produced when it is produced
and so on these people who do not
perform
any of the actual labor dictate the
terms to those who do
and when the demanded products are
finished they own them
in this way the owner class the
capitalists
have complete control of the free market
system from production to sale
okay but that's just the creation and
sale of the actual products right
doesn't the free market still determine
the final price and dictate how and what
companies produce
misguided defenders of capitalism will
say of course
the market is beholden to the law of
supply and demand companies have to
produce what the market demands or they
won't make a profit
this belief in a supposed economic law
is not reflected in reality
like everything else under capitalism
supply and demand is manipulated by
those with money and power
let's look at one recent example this is
one of amazon's biggest uk warehouses
in dunfermline scotland and from inside
where
millions of perfectly good products each
year are sent to be destroyed
secret footage captured in what's known
as the destruction zone
and that calls into question the
company's environmental
and ethical practices
an itv news investigation reveals unsold
laptops
scanned not for delivery but instead
marked
destroy boxes full of electrical items
such as drills shavers
headphones even smart tvs
the list goes on brand new books
still in their wrappers or jewelry
or steel cutlery with that same
instruction
destroyed
one former employee who wishes to remain
anonymous
reveals the scale of what they're asked
to do
so from a friday to a friday our target
was approximately 130 000 items a week
the target to destroy from one centre
was 130
000 items yes there's no rhyme or reason
to what gets destroyed
dyson fans hoover's the occasional
macbook or ipad
or the other day 20 bins filled with
thousands of covered masks still in
their plastic wrappers
separately we followed another lorry as
it headed out
carrying non-electrical items the
destination
a landfill and recycling site only a few
miles from where they've been stored
and in the main still perfectly usable
what's going on here
why are these items being destroyed the
answer is simple
it makes amazon more money to dump
perfectly good laptops tvs and
silverware into a landfill as opposed to
selling it at a loss or donating it to
charity
too much product availability drives
prices down
and it's more profitable to keep demand
high by artificially limiting product
availability
when there's no demand for a product on
the market companies destroy their stock
to create fake demand
take car companies for example when a
new model is coming out
the old ones quietly disappear they
haven't all
been bought the ones they can't sell to
rental companies have been destroyed
same with amazon and their mountains of
unopened ppe
mask use is dropping so in order to
maintain profitable prices
they simply destroy excess stock and by
destroy
i mean dump truckloads of
non-biodegradable waste in landfills
where it will remain forever further
polluting the planet for the sake of
short-term profits
and it's not just consumer goods either
look at the food industry during the
pandemic
american dairy farmers dumped 3.7
million gallons of milk per day
and potato farmers destroyed 1.5 billion
tons of their crop
why because it wouldn't be profitable to
find ways to give it all away
to their credit some potato farmers put
out a call to have anyone come and take
as many potatoes as they wanted
which is certainly better than nothing
but the fact that we have exactly zero
infrastructure in place for the
emergency distribution of food products
is a damning indictment of the soulless
for-profit capitalist system
and farmers aren't even close to the
worst offenders
you've probably seen the video of the
young dunkin donuts worker who
instead of throwing away excess donuts
according to company policy
bagged them up and donated them to the
homeless and his local firefighters
for this act of kindness which cost the
company nothing
this person was fired let's do a little
napkin math
it's not uncommon for a single dunkin
donut store to throw away 5 dozen donuts
or more
per night that's 60 donuts as of june
1st 2021
there are 9291 dunkin donuts locations
in the u.s
if we figure 60 donuts per store per
night that's 557
460 donuts every night 203 million
donuts per year
four billion pounds of donuts just
thrown away
okay but donuts are junk food it's not
like they're keeping healthy meals from
people
well let's look at grocery stores
grocery stores
throw away over 43 billion pounds of
food
every year and that's not just expired
food
according to a recent study a full 50
of the discarded food is still perfectly
edible when it's thrown away
this is an unconscionable practice when
over 23 million americans are food
insecure
to further hammer home the dystopian
nature of our for-profit system
during the pandemic we saw armed guards
blocking people from retrieving food
from dumpsters outside grocery stores
think about that for a minute people are
desperate enough to dig food out of a
dumpster
during the worst pandemic in our
lifetime and those in power decide not
to help distribute food
but to defend our corporate waste with
the threat of violence
the us is not the only country at fault
here other capitalist nations act
similarly
we produce enough food to feed every
human on earth with
plenty to spare but the inherent traits
of capitalism disincentivize a common
sense allocation of resources
in favor of maximizing profit these
tendencies
the tendencies to cut corners generate
tons of waste
and neglect long-term stability exist in
every sector
we've recently seen the consequences of
supposed capitalist efficiency in my
home state of texas and in florida
during last winter's cold snap millions
of texans were left without power or
clean
drinking water many for days or even
weeks on end
this was the direct result of the
reckless privatization of our electrical
grid
in order to cut costs and maximize
profits ercot neglected to weatherproof
our electrical infrastructure
the result was catastrophic and future
failures will only get worse as the
effects of climate change intensify
florida is another prime candidate for
truly dystopian climate fallout
as we speak the florida coast is
becoming increasingly
unsafe thanks to erosion and rising sea
levels and yet luxury accommodations
continue to spring up all over miami
on june 24th champlain towers south a
condo building and surfside
collapsed killing and as yet
undetermined number of people
likely over 100 for years the developers
had known about critical flaws in the
integrity of the building
which would have cost them an estimated
9 million dollars to rectify
common sense and a concern for safety
would have prompted them to make the
repairs
the profit motive disincentivized that
action and no repairs were made
the end result was the entirely
preventable collapse of a 13-story
building and the loss of dozens of
innocent lives
florida is one of the more obvious cases
of at-risk infrastructure
but the rest of the country isn't far
behind the pacific northwest has been
experiencing temperatures
never before seen in that region the
heat literally melting electrical wires
and buckling roads
the efficient thing to do would be to
invest the money to repair and
weatherproof our infrastructure
thereby preventing future shipping
shutdowns traffic problems and
catastrophic failures like bridge
collapses
the capitalist notion of efficiency will
result in us doing the absolute
bare minimum to restore the lowest
possible level of adequate function
to maintain our precarious operation so
what are the takeaways here capitalism's
vision of efficiency
is predicated not on ensuring the
long-term function or sustainability of
our systems
or the common sense allocation of
resources labor or products
but on minimizing costs and maximizing
profits
efficiency is just a euphemism for cost
cutting destructive
wasteful practices short-sightedness and
criminal negligence
it removes the human factor from the
equation and centers capital
instead actual efficiency has to take
into account the longevity of systems
and the sustainability of practices and
products
it's not efficient to overproduce and
then dump millions of tons of unopened
products into landfills
it's tremendously wasteful it takes
labor power
raw materials and carbon emissions to
produce those goods
which are then discarded and add to the
ever-increasing human toll on the
environment
it's not efficient to let mountains of
perfectly good food rot in dumpsters
when millions of americans don't have
enough to eat
even if you take a capitalist approach
wouldn't it make more sense to ensure
that your workers are properly nourished
so that they can work at full
performance
what about making accommodations for
future pandemics or other crises
it will be much more expensive to come
up with emergency distribution methods
during a crisis
than to plan ahead and implement those
systems slowly same with infrastructure
it's not efficient to build high-rises
that will collapse into the sea in 10
years
or to neglect weatherizing electrical
grids roads or bridges
nothing this country does is efficient
in any real sense it's wasteful
short-sighted and inhumane the
capitalist notion of efficiency
is a sham it exists only as an excuse
for the genocidal adherence to the
profit motive
so no capitalism is not the most
efficient system
it doesn't deserve to be called
efficient at all people are slowly
coming around to that fact
let's hope it doesn't take many more
collapsed buildings statewide power
outages
or breadlines to put the final nail in
the coffin
i mentioned climate change a number of
times in this video
it's a prime example of capitalism's
short-sightedness and how we fail to
take into account
enormous consequences even a handful of
years in the future
if you'd like to see how climate change
and capitalist inefficiency are
affecting coastal cities like the one i
mentioned earlier
i highly recommend you check out miami
beach underwater on curiosity stream
curiosity stream is an established
streaming platform with a solid track
record of caring about great educational
content
and the financial security of those who
produce it they've got thousands of
non-fiction titles from some of the best
filmmakers in the game
as you probably know youtube doesn't
treat its creators very well
that's why some of my youtuber friends
and i teamed up to build nebula
so we don't have to worry about
demonetization as educational creators
ourselves
we love curiosity stream so we've worked
out a deal
where if you sign up for curiosity
stream at the link below you'll also get
access to nebula
100 free that's less than 15 bucks a
year for both curiosity stream
and nebula which in my humble opinion is
a pretty great deal
since you're already on the internet
watching my video why not spend some
time learning about fascinating topics
on curiosity stream or check out
nebula's original content
including my upcoming series on the
resurgence of fascism you can also watch
all my videos as they were intended
ad free there really is something for
everyone and by signing up at the link
below
you're helping us produce more content
without the fear of demonetization give
curiosity stream a shot
and get free access to nebula when you
sign up using the link below
it really does help support my channel
and educational creators all across
youtube
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more like it consider subscribing
to stay up to date with my latest
episodes
if you hated it go ahead and drop a
thumbs down you can check out my
previous episodes by clicking the links
on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week